question numéro 3 128 de monsieur alain
gournac à madame la ministre de
l'écologie du développement durable et
de l'énergie
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre weil chers collègues j'ai
entendu un bruit c'était pas un bruit de
feux ou d'une bûche
j'ai entendu un bruit on interdirait les
français la possibilité de faire comme
mon père appelait une flambée 1 en
disant on va se faire une petite flambée
pour que la famille puisse se retrouver
et puis et puis je rencontre un émoi
terrible chez les franciliens
je rencontre des habitants de ma bonne
ville de pec dans les yvelines qui me
disent monsieur le sénateur est il vrai
que l'on va empêcher de pouvoir réaliser
des feux de cheminée on va partir de
bon tu dis non non non non non non non
ça m'étonnerait écoutez j'ai pas les
éléments c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui
madame la ministre je viens vers vous
pour avoir ces informations
parce que sincèrement au moment on est
en train de tout mettre par terre dans
les références le fait je prends dans ma
ville mais je peux prendre dans la
france toute entière qu'il ya des
personnes qui souhaitent trouver de
maison avec une cheminée avec une
cheminée ou à ceux qui n'ont pas la
cheminée la cheminée quand ils achètent
de se dire eh ben moi ma première
acquisition après mon cette maison c'est
de faire installer une cheminée attal et
s'y installe une cheminée qu'on a pu le
droit à partir de 2015 de réaliser un
feu de cheminée alors c'est très
intelligent parce que c'est donc j'ai pu
soyez ouverts à toi y est ouvert à vous
d'aller piquer sa offrant cette faille
est ouvert et puis d'autres foyers
fermés bon et donc madame la ministre
franchement moi je ne vois pas là
l'aspect de dangers de la flambée est
sincèrement les franciliens mais les
français ne comprennent pas que ya de
bonnes raisons pour leur interdire ce
petit plaisir qu'ils allaient en
fonctionne quand même un peu plus divers
que l'été
mais moi en tant que législateur modeste
modeste agitateurs je trouve aberrant
aberrant ça discrédite totalement nos
engagements que d'aller dire à nos
compatriotes et bien là là le feu de
cheminée site vous pouvez baisser c'est
fini on n'en fait plus et vous allez
vous mettre à côté du radiateur
électrique qu'on se retrouve en famille
à côté du radiateur électrique
c'est assez sympathique un mois vraiment
je n'en reviens pas madame la ministre
je vous le dis je reviens pas alors
qu'on souhaite défendre la santé
publique bien sûr que oui que je suis
pour mais sincèrement le de nous dire
que ça va avantager parce qu'il y avait
des petites particules qui partirait de
et puis et puis une dernière chose que
je veux dire maintenant ça se fait en
catimini par ce que j'ai vu ça nulle
part un juge je lis pas mal de documents
et faire ça en catimini
je trouve que c'est pas correct nous
devons respecter les français madame la
ministre je sais que vous êtes très
attentive à tout cela et c'est pour ça
que je vais écouter votre réponse avec
beaucoup d'intérêt merci mon cher
collègue la parole est à madame delphine
batho ministre de l'écologie du
développement durable et de l'énergie
monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur je vais vous répondre de la
façon la plus la plus franche
évidemment tout le monde apprécie un feu
de cheminée
maintenant il ya aussi un problème qu'il
faut regarder en face et que 60% de la
population france est exposée à une
qualité de l'air dégradé avec des effets
sur la santé qui sont avérées en termes
d'irritation d'allergie d'asthme
d'insuffisance respiratoire grave de
maladies cardiovasculaires de cancers et
on estime ainsi que la partie de la
pollution aux particules en france est à
l'origine d'environ 42 mille décès
prématurés chaque année selon une étude
d'impact de la commission européenne
notre pays accuse aussi un retard
important dans le respect de la
directive européenne sur la qualité de
l'air elie à la menace d'un contentieux
avec une condamnation lourde par la
commission européenne c'est un fait que
les appareils de chauffage au bois
anciens et les foyers ouverts
sont fortement émetteurs de particules
les flambées et donc le feu de cheminée
représente ainsi 27% en ile-de-france
des émissions de particules les leviers
pour réduire significativement ses
émissions sans perte de confort sont
importants puisque je rappelle qu'un
foyer ouvert et mais six à huit fois
plus de particules qu'un foyer fermé à
l'aide d'un insert et qu'une chaudière
bois émet jusqu'à 15 fois moins de
particules qu'une cheminée ouverte c'est
la raison pour laquelle les services de
l'état en charge de l'élaboration du
plan de protection de l'atmosphère pour
l'île de france ont proposé après
concertation puisqu'il ya eu
concertation des mesures visant à
limiter les émissions de particules du
aux équipements de combustion individuel
au bois ce plan a été approuvé par
arrêté interpréfectoral le 25 mars 2013
il prévoit l'interdiction des de
l'utilisation des foyers ouverts à
partir du 1er janvier 2015 en zone
sensible
je rappelle que le préfet de la région
ile de france avait déjà interdit en
2007 l'utilisation des foyers ouverte
ouverts sauf pour lapointe et l'agrément
à paris la combustion de bois sera
totalement interdite sauf dérogation par
arrêté préfectoral et dans la zone
sensible hors paris seront autorisés les
cheminées à foyer fermé par un cerf ou
un poil performance c'est à dire doté
d'un bon rendement ce qu'on appelle
flamme verte
le remplacement des équipements de plus
de 15 ans par des installations
performantes sera recommandée et
encourager j'ajoute que ces mesures ont
été discutés dans le cadre du conseil
national de l'air que ça a fait l'objet
d'une concertation importante avec
l'ensemble des associations et des
partenaires de la politique de l'état en
matière d'amélioration de la qualité de
l'air merci madame la ministre monsieur
gournac madame la ministre
j'apprécie votre franchise parce que je
crois que c'est important quand on se
pose ce genre de questions mais
globalement je vais vous demander de me
faire une petite note si vous avez aimé
services peuvent le faire pour y
expliquer ça à mes alpi quoi
peur aux habitants de campagne pour leur
dire tout ce que vous venez de dire
ils vont me dire attendez là en acier
d'atr kefu un sénateur qui est fou alors
moi alors c'est sûr que l'on va mettre
aussi en place une police ou metropolis
des foyers ouverts
c'est à dire on viendra regardera on
regardera sur les toits et puis quand on
verra de la fumée on regardera si aller
vers touchez pas quelle couleur pour ce
nom madame les mises moi je proteste
qu'on défend alors je suis pour qu'on en
défend les problèmes de santé oui oui je
mets ça chèrement à la campagne dans mon
beau département où tout autour de paris
de se retrouver en famille vous le savez
bien d'ailleurs de se retrouver en
famille autour de autour de cette
flambée puisque je vous dis la famille
gournac c'était ça c'était la flambée
papa disent on va faire une flambée et
et est quand même quelque chose
d'important c'est un endroit alors c'est
pas pour chauffer madame la ministre
c'est pas pour chauffer vous avez raison
ces deux-là points c'est souvent on fait
une flambée c'est pour pour chauffer la
maison il ya la plupart du temps de le
chauffage central
mais cette possibilité la retirer cette
possibilité madame la ministre je trouve
ça tout à fait désagréable et je reviens
sur ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure il ya
des repères on a une organisation de vie
et petit à petit c'était le camembert
1 parce qu'il était proche et pas quoi
et on peut continuer comme ça et fur et
à mesure eh bien les français perdent
pied et les français ne croient plus du
tout aux politiques que le politique
soit capable de prendre
les bonnes décisions alors je sais que
vous avez terriblement envie de me
répondre à ma réponse mais nadal et nice
vous pouvez pas le faire ici mais vous
pouvez peut-être peut le faire d'accord
dehors merci madame amis je vous la
parole pour un retour de flamme
je vous en prie je ne veux pas par bon
règlement du sénat je veux être dans le
respect des règles simplement pour vous
dire je comprends parfaitement ce que
vous dites il faut faire un vrai travail
de pédagogie en même temps je crois que
beaucoup d'habitants de l'île de france
sont préoccupés par les problèmes de
pollution notamment les bronchiolites
des enfants donc il ya un travail de
pédagogie à faire à travers de ces
mesures c'est 61 % des émissions aux
particules du secteur résidentiel qui
serait diminué donc ce sont des mesures
efficaces si la date d'application et
2015 et non pas 2013 c'est précisément
pour avoir le temps de faire ses
explications et aussi de déployer des
mesures d'accompagnement puisque vous
savez qu'à travers le crédit d'impôt
développement durable
le remplacement par exemple d'un foyer
ouvert par un foyer fermé et les
évolutions que j'évoquais sur les poêles
à bois etc sont éligibles aux aides du
crédit d'impôt développement durable et
c'est évident qu'ils aient un travail de
pédagogie à faire il ne faut pas le
cacher